bonjour estelle alors les manifestant-es
qu'ils sont nombreux déjà et bien
samantha vous allez le voir adhère mois
sur ces images de bassiste marc de
reuver professionnels du secteur médico
social qui sont en train de se mobiliser
aujourd'hui mobilisation pour plus de
reconnaissance alors ce secteur il
englobe de nombreuses professions les
salariés des étapes par exemple mais
aussi à de l'aide à domicile ou encore
du handicap
puis il demande plus de moyens et plus
de moyens de moyens pour eux et bien
cela passe par des effectifs en plus des
augmentations salariales du temps de
formation en plus aussi globalement et
en ces temps de pandémie il exige à
l'arrêt des fermetures de lits dans les
hôpitaux
et puis l'art est aussi à des plans
d'économies à synonyme pour eux de
suppressions de postes et il ya de la
colère ici je vous propose d'écouter ces
deux témoignages
là on est tous épuisés on est en train
de crever nous à l'hôpital bayer au en
pleine pandémie en plaques ovine
on avait des sacs poubelle dans certains
services pour se protéger on est en
colère aussi pour de reconnaître qu'ils
sont décédés est-ce qu'on a des
collectes sont décédés vous en entendez
parler vous
on attend de l'argent
le point d'indicé relevé évidemment et
surtout pas une considération écrite
considération de morale que les
politiques n'ont pas du tout et puis il
ya aussi les fameuses oublier un du
ségur de la santé il reproche au
gouvernement de ne pas avoir appliqué à
leur secteur les avancées obtenues lors
de ces négociations et notamment le
versement de 180 euros 183 euros
d'augmentation de salaire celle passée
le cas par exemple de hanna qui nous
avons parlé ici analysant de sa voix
elle est aide soignante en psychiatrie
et elle n'a pas eu ce versement et cc
personnel et bien ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi ils ont été exclus
il souhaite donc obtenir l'égalité
salariale entre tous les agents et
salariés d'un même établissement noté
aussi un qu'outre paris de nombreuses
mobilisations sont prévues partout en
france c'est le cas par exemple de
nantes
rodez ou encore tarbes pour ne citer que
ces villes merci beaucoup à vous
installe farges pour toutes ces
précisions d'avoir trouvé tout à l'heure